peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cours d'histoire
boudeur frondeur à beit envahi la gaule
il ne reste qu'un seul virage qui ne
peut plus pâle esclavage
[Musique]
c'est une bande dessinée vendue dans le
monde entier mais qu'est ce qu'ils
disent est abruti
il faut le livre est à césar la boule
est bien attaché à son genre
[Musique]
non
m
assez vite
au dernier rang mon petit bourg paul
propre tout sauf en gymnastique
je ne déconne pas mon propos astérix
était plus fort que tous les boutons
malabar
tous les gros et les chronos et même
conan le barbare
pas mal du tout mademoiselle prévoyait
se produire en éducation sexuelle
alors quand je lis astérix à quoi
pensez-vous
attention ces familles région est petit
croix qui sert ne rend pas dans le match
tu sais pour expliquer un détaillant
match nul archi nul vous aurez vous
était tout nu dans l'arène par les gars
de leurs enfants alors
pour vous
[Musique]
voir
ça va
[Musique]
finale messieurs
ravi en rien stoppé au pire de boulettes
au réfectoire tu me dégoûtes iphone
l'élu estime sa peluche le lancet les
romains dans les airs giro-tour belle va
mettre derrière la tête enfoncée dans la
terre va pour mes parents mademoiselle
air fawaz même pas française est laïque
et le monde il existe un héros comme
astérix
[Musique]
quel rapport
c'est lamentable vous serez hérité à la
tribu belge guy côté sur un temps notre
père vous serez rouler dans les prix
blanc
[Musique]
mais
ok
[Musique]
comme à nice
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]